(dramatic piano music)
- We live in a country that
has incredible abundance.
But if you were to add
up all of the hungry people,
in Los Angeles County, and
its contiguous counties
as well, you'd have a state of hunger
the size of New Mexico, or West Virginia.
Two and a half million people.
To me, it is a mandate for
us to do better around this.
And it's so simple, it's
just sharing abundance.
(uplifting instrumental music)
My name's Rick Nahmias, I'm founder
and Executive Director of Food Forward.
Our mission is to recover
fresh produce that
would otherwise go to waste, and get it
to people in need.
We started in 2009, and it really was just
walking around my neighborhood, and seeing
all these fruit trees
dripping with citrus,
that I realized that
with a few volunteers,
there might be a project here
that I could help facilitate.
Eight and a half years later,
and 43 million pounds later, here we are.
(bouncing marimba music)
We have fed over one and a
half million people this year.
We have three programs; backyard harvest,
literally going into folks' homes
who have agreed to have us in there,
taking excess produce from their trees,
sometimes their gardens.
The second program that was added a couple
years later was Farmer's Market Recovery.
We're at about 24 Farmer's
Markets every single week
with volunteer teams.
And then the big one is
the wholesale recovery,
which works kind of
under cloak or darkness.
We get up super early, usually before
the sun even comes up, and are out there
with our trucks gathering pallets,
and entire truckloads of food that is
perfectly viable, but for whatever reason
would otherwise end up in a trash dump.
We're looking at things that just might
have a slight discoloration,
or a slight bruise on them.
It still has weeks left to its
life, but it's not perfect.
And that's where we get called.
(upbeat instrumental music)
We have learned that
hunger hides in plain sight
here in society.
There should be no shame around it.
Unfortunately there is, but the more that
we bring abundance out,
and really give people
food with dignity, and give them quality,
healthy, nutritious food, these issues
will slowly go away.
(dramatic orchestral music)